okay let's go
[Music]
Deadpool to full trailer now out and I
know that I have said in the past I try
and avoid trailers after initial teasers
it does depend on the movie some movies
I'm much more worried about being
spoiled than others Deadpool as a
franchise so far at least has not been
particularly plot heavy the plot has not
been the reason you go so I'm not
necessarily as worried about getting a
better sense of what the heck is going
on so I did watch this trailer there's
some stuff that I like there's some
stuff that I'm iffy on it's all gonna be
question of how it balances now before I
get into this let me say I am not
addressing any of the back and forth
questions about how well the movie did
or didn't test long story very short
there was a rumor that came out that its
test screenings were horrible and then
official numbers came out about the test
screenings that actually showed it to be
incredibly high I don't want to deal
with any of that I'm just not to deal
with it all I'm talking about is the
trailer that dropped today that's it so
how did this go well it gave me what I
would want out of a second trailer for
something like Deadpool it gave me a
little bit more of a sense of what the
structure at least initially is going to
be and what folks roles in this thing is
so we get a little bit more cable and it
looks like at least initially that he
and Deadpool are gonna be at odds it
looks like Deadpool is trying to stop
what cables trying to do I have no doubt
that will not be the case for the whole
movie and you know at some point they
are going to team up and there will be
some other villain because I mean cable
is gonna be straight guy too - Deadpool
that's that is the dynamic that works
when you pair those two characters
together so I do think it is smart
though as far as a trailer goes to only
show us segments of them being against
each other and not giving away stuff
that probably doesn't happen for I don't
know 45 minutes or an hour into the
movie so that's a good call as far as
that goes Josh Brolin definitely playing
this straight and he looks pretty good
in the part I think it's it's solid
casting as far as that goes I've kind of
I don't want to say a badmouth Josh
Brolin I've never been
overly impressed with him but he feels
like a good fit for cable so I'm down
with that I love the little bits that we
get of Domino I'm very excited to see
how she pans out there's Terry Crews for
all of one shot but that alone makes me
smile because I really like Terry Crews
I'm a big Brooklyn nine-nine fam what
can I say and then of course there's
deadpool himself oh we've got other
recurring characters we've got TJ Miller
coming back in Marana back Ren and
whoever plays the taxi driver I don't
know his name and his blind roommate and
all of that so I like the amount of plot
that we got the plot that we got so far
looks like solid foundation to be doing
this movie i o- on a teenager warheads
back to that's a big one for me that's a
big win but so what do we have beyond
that well we get some more looks at the
action which looks good it looks
hard-hitting and it looks most
importantly more varied because
ultimately when you actually broke the
first Deadpool down there were really
only two three ish action scenes in it
they were just broken up in weird ways
to have it be spread more across the
movie but that did mean that we kept
coming back to the action scene that's
going on on the on the overpass and we
keep coming back to that for awhile and
they stretch several scenes and
sequences out of that um this we're
getting a lot more variations on
settings so it looks like they're not
being as restricted as far as what they
can afford to do what they can afford to
set up but the action still looks good
it still looks fun and hard-hitting Oh
another high point the music cues I like
them both I love how it starts with I'm
all out of love and the devil just right
I love that Deadpool even though he is
basically indestructible still has you
know I what was some would consider a
reasonable response every now and again
to be vastly outnumbered and I'm
assuming if that one maybe being out of
ammunition which is just to run so I I
like that does it make sense could he
take them yeah probably still but it's
funny so we do it so I'm fine with that
normally I'm not huge on the kind of
humor that feels like it doesn't totally
match characters but him being a meta
character he's allowed to sort of bend
those rules a little bit which brings us
to the humor now the humor that I like
best as you might have guessed was the
meta humor I really enjoyed the jokes
about we need them young enough to be in
a sustainable franchise for 10 to 12
years I love that joke I loved the
please tell me they got that in slow-mo
joke those were great well I didn't love
him what Franklin made me cringe were
the poop jokes the jokes that seemed to
just be hey he said a bad word now I
don't have a problem with cursing I mean
I try not to do it on my own channel but
it's not because I'm a prude I'm not
like oh my sensitive ears but like to me
the joke has to be more than just the
swear that you said it is possible for a
square to elevate a joke but it can't be
the joke in and of itself at least not
for me that doesn't work and you know
bathroom humor
almost never works for me that's a
rarity now that's not me going that that
therefore it's bad that's me pointing
out that there are still humor elements
in this that are not the kind of humor
that resonates to me and they're sharing
space with the kind of humor that I
really love so how much I'm going to
enjoy this movie because I'm definitely
going to see it is going to come down to
where the balance is and what just what
the percentages of the meta jokes to the
poop jokes to just not even overdoing
humor and just letting the action scenes
be action scenes how much comedies
worked into those action sees that
that's the thing I think this movie has
all the components and the pieces and
the cast and the concept to be really
really good but it's all gonna come down
to the blend in the mixed how those
things actually work together I think
they will work together but is really at
least for my taste a question of
percentages what gets the most emphasis
and wow I did not love moments like that
like in the beginning of the taxi guy
driver saying he crapped his pants and
Deadpool going no I think that was me
I'm like that that made me immediately
lose the smile that I'd had at with the
initial joke of him you know running to
the taxi but then other stuff happened
that gave me that grin back so it really
is just gonna come down to how often
does that happen
and how quickly do we move away from it
because another thing that I generally
like in comedies fast paced comedy boy
you can't snap very well with these
sorts of gloves off hanck fast-paced
comedy so the main reason that I like
fast-paced comedy is when you keep a
good pace that means that even if it
joke fails you move off of it so quickly
that it doesn't really hurt the movie
that well it's when jokes get drawn out
that if it doesn't work it becomes
insufferable so I think you know
everything that I'm seeing here is
leaning towards I'm at the very least
gonna like it and possibly even love it
we will see for the record my feeling on
the first one was really good in a
really good time but I could see where
it was limited in terms of its budget
and sort of working on with with an
origin story narrative this this version
of Deadpool of wait specifically would
like when he doesn't have the mass seems
a lot more carefree which I am down with
he was a little angsty in the first one
which was fine I mean introductory stuff
we got to get audiences used to him but
they know him now let's go wild and that
is what I hope we will get from Deadpool
too so those are my thoughts on the
second trailer for Deadpool 2 or DP 2 or
is it actually getting released as
untitled Deadpool sequel I actually
don't know I haven't been able to
confirm that but whatever it's being
called what are your thoughts on the new
trailer whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
do all the stuff like like and subscribe
and support me on patreon maybe you know
if you like what I do so links for all
that stuff and more is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]